um
i was a targeter at the cia so
there are different types of targeters
there are what i think
a lot of people see in the movies are
kinetic targeters like the military guys
who
literally target a person to drop a bomb
on them with a drone
there are targeting analysts who are
people who
find those people and analyze where they
might be
or you know where they might be
or or who might be around them that's
also targetable but i did operational
targeting
targeting so i was given
instructions you know we want to know
this is the intel
right like this is the intel that we
have a gap in and we have to fill
so my job was to find who could fill
that gap in our intel
and then identify the most likely people
that we could approach
to give us that intel and then put
together an entire
like dossier on them uh so they could be
approached
so they could be bumped so they could be
approached so we can make friends with
them
and then convince them that telling us
their secrets is the best thing for them
okay so i asked your husband this the
first time he came on the show and i'm
gonna ask you the same thing because i'm
interested in your perspective
but what in your mind are the mo are the
biggest misconceptions of the cia
you know so funny story i never intended
to work for the cia
so i am probably one of those people who
had like huge misconceptions in the
beginning
i applied to the cia on a whim
i was actually looking to join the
department of state
or any other federal government agency
it was my last year of college and i was
at a job fair
and i walked right by their booth and my
applications to the federal government
were were going and nobody had called me
back and i was getting worried and i
thought you know what i was like
last ditch like effort i'll apply to the
cia like there's an application online
like i didn't stop to talk to them i was
like oh those cie people
so i get a call back after i apply and
every step of the interview process i
had these misconceptions where i was
like i am not a james bond
i am not like i am not
a liar i don't want to do this shady
stuff
like um i am not comfortable with like
overthrowing government so every step of
the way right but
every step of the interview process i'm
meeting these people
who are just like you and me they are
very friendly people
they are very intelligent people and i
start to learn more about the agency and
its mission
so i think that a lot of the
misconceptions is that the cia is
like a dirty place right that people
without morals work there and we do
dirty sneaky things and
you know we're working you know on it's
like black ops or doing you know like
not cool black ops but like you know
overthrowing governments and
you know manipulating people into to
doing things they don't want to do and
none of that that is not true
right like people just like you and me
work there
really intelligent people doing really
incredibly important work
like intelligence is an absolutely
necessary part
of um government interaction
right like when you're at high level i
mean even at low level honestly
different types of intelligence but on a
government level for sure
intelligence is crucial diplomacy is
fed by intelligence you can't have
diplomacy without it
you won't be successful at diplomacy
without it in my opinion
so now were you i mean what was your
perspective your
your outsider perspective before you
actually got in and started learning it
and meeting people
so i was a social worker before i joined
the agency
um and i was working with uh refugees
and asylum seekers primarily
who were being relocated to the united
states
so my my vision
of what the cia was before i
joined was purely from the movies you
know really cool gadgets and
everybody knows how to do kung fu like
everybody knows five languages
um you know everybody was cool and good
looking and it was really
i'm a huge fan of james bond so i really
was like
this is the agency once i got there i
realized it's
it's a diverse place and one of the
biggest
things that really hit me when i got to
the agency is how many
different jobs there actually are so all
the movies are about the exciting
case officer right the james bond
um the ethan hunt but you get there and
there are hr people there are
people who clean the waste baskets there
are
you know cooks there are analysts there
are mechanics
there are graphic designers there are
really yes
like there's a print shop there people
work that
you know like they're i.t people so it's
just like
any other it was it was insane like how
cool it was to walk in and to see the
seal and you have to get past the guards
with your special badge and all of that
felt super cool
but you walk in and it's cubicles
and people doing like a plethora of
different
jobs like any other business
like any other government organization
to keep it running
you just happen to work on things that
are
super cool that most people don't know
about that's what i enjoyed the most was
kind of having this insider insight into
world events that i was already
interested in and then i had an
even even more of an insider perspective
where i was like this is really cool
and i can affect things in a way even if
a small way
that nobody will ever know about and for
me being behind the scenes is huge like
i love being behind the scenes like
affecting somebody that nobody ever
knows i even touched that's
that makes me feel good right i see the
end result and i'm like boom i did that
great
so now when you got there did you get to
sort of choose the path that you took
or did they do that for you so in the
interview process um that i went through
um
i was uh i was going for
they have different tracks so i was
going for a certain track and there were
like three different
job descriptions that i could go for um
i picked one i entered i decided shortly
after
they have a really long orientation
period
and then a really long training period
so i decided
i originally was a desk officer and i
decided that targeting was a better fit
for me
when i entered in 2007 targeting was
brand new
they had just started it it used to be
that case officers themselves
would do that kind of work they would be
the ones that found targets and figured
out how to approach them
but it really wasn't efficient for them
to be doing that they really need to be
out in the field
meeting people so they created an entire
job description
for people who specialized in finding
who they were going to meet so then all
they have to do is spend an hour with me
and i say this is the guy here's his
photo here's his family here's
everything we know about him he's going
to be
at this place at this time he likes this
kind of stuff
go you know go meet him and be friends
if they spend an hour with me it saves
them a ton of time
i can go much more in depth because i'm
interested
than the case officer would be able to
because they have a million other things
going on so um
yeah so for me i was able to change
tracks
during the training period and then be
certified as a targeter
i